hey guys real quick so you don't think i  fell off the face of the planet i'm  getting married up here in sonoma  california this week so i'm doing a full  online shutdown which i announced on  twitter but then i realized some of you  youtubers might not be on the twitter  anyway i am disconnecting i'm recharging  focusing on the personal life for a  little bit i will be back beginning of  september the all new reuben report  debuts on aura tv on september 9th trust  me uh you guys are gonna dig the first  guest we have a ton of awesome stuff in  store for you and i'm gonna come back uh  refreshed and recharged and focused like  never before we're on to something i can  feel it i think you guys can feel it and  i'm really psyched but in the meantime  i'm just gonna enjoy this for a little  bit and uh be back soon thanks